the Iron Man 3 trailer came out last
week and I'll be the extension out
awesome very exciting to see some
prolonged images of the Mandarin I think
we were all surprised to find out who
was playing the Mandarin when we first
saw the trailer where we yeah not as
intimidating not as intimidating as I
thought he'd be they called me a teacher
that's [ __ ] too fat to fight right
there man well you got all the rings you
don't need you know ten rings and rings
yeah I don't if you count the sphincter
I'm following that that was genius yeah
that was pretty strong Kevin also had a
bad week in the UK and if you saw that
or not he he had a he was late for a
show he had a bad birthday party and
then he tried to pick a fight with a
paparazzo don't know if you saw that or
not that was a little embarrassing for
Kevin Kevin storming out of the SUV
trying to approach him have you see
you've seen the real picture right of
course yes yes it looks like that dude
is picking him up oh yeah that's either
that's a very big dude or Justin is a
dwarf oh and lastly this thing usually
is just the photographs but Matt from
Harrisburg Pennsylvania sent in a little
audio Kevin he said credit to black
Jesus HD for the music stems and to
whatever strain was smoking that night
but Kevin a couple episodes ago a while
back went off on this book of Mormon
rant he's seen it go see it it's on the
road now spreading out across United
States it's in the UK as well if you
haven't seen it see it is the best piece
of art ever produced by human beings
ever could you're not overselling that a
name no I'm telling you I've never met
anybody who's been like I heard you say
it and I saw it you're out of your mind
everybody's like it's better than you
even said I'm saying like Sistine Chapel
and stuff I mean there's other things
that have been done Sistine Chapel
you're paying a [ __ ] ceiling deal man
these [ __ ] came up with don't
[ __ ] too baby yeah that's Kevin's
favorite song from that musical so Matt
from Harrisburg said sometimes he gets
an itch do a mashup and he just can't
rest until it's finished so here is a
mash-up of Kevin singing from the Book
of Mormon and Carly Rae Jepsen singing
her hit
a little taste
[Music]
[Music]
very good
that's your audio Kevin for the night my
I got a 13 year old kid right and she's
on to like dark music and [ __ ] like that
chance metal why not I played that in
the car once and she just looked at me
so appalled she reached over and she
shut her off and she was like no dad no
bubbly and fun she's like no dad no so I
can't listen to it around my kid the
worm in my office is [ __ ] nobody's
around like I'm not nuts right it's a
fun cooking it's like Jessie's Girl I
always get those people give me [ __ ]
because I'm a huge Rick Springfield fan
because those three minutes [ __ ]
well-crafted pop songs with some but
it's really done right you just can't
beat it gets in your skin it's like
[ __ ] heroin it's musical heroin you
know it's bad for you but you're like
[ __ ] jamming it into your veins I just
snorted I don't shoot it ah you know
what you're missing man
[Music]
you
[Music]